[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's america's
roman catholic bishops are set to
approve new guidance for giving holy
communion it's become an issue that's
getting new attention because of
president biden some catholic leaders
say the president and others who support
abortion rights are not fit to receive
communion mr biden says pope francis
gave him the go-ahead when they met last
month ed o'keefe reports on the argument
over one of the church's most basic
rights and who should be allowed to
receive it
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy spirit
at a meeting of american catholic
bishops in baltimore the pope's top
envoy to the united states urged them to
listen ahead of a debate
on adopting a document about holy
communion that was sparked in part by
the election of president biden the holy
father says
a church that teaches
must be firstly a church that listens
mr biden met with pope francis last
month at the vatican
the visit and the pope's apparent
encouragement to continue receiving
communion came as american catholic
bishops continue debating whether
catholic politicians like the president
and house speaker nancy pelosi who
support abortion rights should be barred
from communion if they don't follow
church doctrine that opposes the
procedure
certain bishops say they're trying to
clarify the importance of communion amid
recent polls showing many catholics
don't fully understand or believe in the
sacrament
this has been lingering for a long time
san francisco's archbishop salvatore
cordelioni and other supporters of the
document being voted on have said it's
not directed at any particular catholic
but the election of president biden a
church-going catholic who is also takes
positions that are direct attacks on
human life uh gave more impetus to this
so in essence the the election of
president biden is what compelled you
all to say
we need to have a bigger conversation
about this i think this gave a stimulus
to doing it the president attends mass
nearly every weekend and has said that
his catholic faith is central to his
public life
he's known francis since the start of
his papacy and has said they've bonded
over the death of bo biden
father anthony figueredo a cbs news
papal contributor believes what american
bishops are doing runs counter to the
pope's wishes it's a very different
vision to some of the bishops who want
to use the eucharist as a political
football pope francis says no
to a political football archbishop
cordeliani is one of those church
leaders who said he would deny communion
to the president because of his support
for abortion rights the white house
declined to comment on the bishops
conference and when asked about it last
month during his visit to the vatican
the president would only save the
conference that it's a private
conversation
tony
it is a personal matter also becoming
more political though ed thank you very
much